[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بالنسبه لقانون الشركات احنا في بدايه
الطريق او يعني في الحجر الاساس اليوم
كسناديق مثل صندوق نمى اللي يستثمر في
مستخدم
او يعني القروض القابله للتحول الى الى
اسد الى الى اسهم
واشهرها حاضنه عندها
للاسف اليوم لا نستطيع ان نستخدم بعض هذه
الادوات في قوانين الشركات
المحليه ولذلك نطلب من
شركاتنا شركات تقنيه في منطقه ان تؤسس
القابضه في اماكن
القانون الشركات فيها ناضج بحيث تستحوذ
هذه الشركات القابضه على الشركات المحليه
100% في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
مصطلحين ياتوا في في بالي
التوسع والكفاءه يعني انت ذكرتي بعض
الشركات
ابل على هذا تليفوني هو تليفون
ومكتبك للعمل وكاميرا وجهازك الموسيقي
وهناك كفاءه عاليه تقدمها الشركات التقنيه
لا تستطيع الشركات التقليديه
يعني اكبر شركه
اوتيلات في العالم لا تمتلك فندق واحد
اكبر شركه تاكسي في العالم اوبر لا تمتلك
سياره واحده
لترى في الشركات
التقنيه لا يعني مستحيل ان ترى مرادف لها
في الشركات التقليديه